LEBRON NOW HANDLING THE BALL.
BOGDANOVIC GOES RIGHT UP
AGAINST HIM. LEBRON TRYING TO
PUT A MOVE ON. NOW A LITTLE
DANCE. LEBRON SPINNING LEBRON
SHOOTING.
>> AND TO GO ME. TO GO BARE.
CONTACT. SCORE FORCES JAZZ TO
WANT TO TAKE IT TIMEOUT.
THERE'S 3 MINUTES AND 17 LEFT
AS LEBRON PUT IT UP, PUTS IT
IN AND IT'S A 94 91 GAMES.
AND THE JAZZ AND QUIN SNYDER
WILL SUFFER THEIR SIXTH
CONSECUTIVE ROAD LOSS.
AND THE LAKERS WILL TAKE THE
SEASON SERIES AGAINST UTAH IN
THIS, THE SECOND MEETING OF
THREE.
FRANK VOGEL TOLD US, RUSSELL
WESTBROOK PLAYED WELL AGAINST
GOLDEN STATE.
PLAYED WELL TONIGHT HERE.
6 OF 13.
16 POINTS.
LIMITED HIS TURNOVERS.
HAD AN ASSIST.
AND CLOSED THE GAME OUT AT THE
FREE-THROW LINE.
HE HAD EVERYBODY TAKE EXTRA FREE
THROWS AFTER THAT GOLDEN STATE
GAME.
TONIGHT, IT PAID DIVIDENDS.
>> Doris: THAT'S A HECK OF A
WIN.
>> Mark: A MAGISTERIAL
PERFORMANCE BY LeBRON JAMES.
EMBRACED BY A SUPER BOWL
CHAMPION.
THAT'S HOW THEY DO IT IN L.A.
THESE DAYS.
MITCHELL WITH AN IMPRESSIVE
LINE.
HE HAD 37 AND 5 ASSISTS.
NOT QUITE ENOUGH TONIGHT.
AS LeBRON JAMES AND HIS 33
POINTS, 8 REBOUND, 6 ASSISTS.
SCORES 25 OR MORE IN HIS 23rd
CONSECUTIVE GAME.
WHAT A NIGHT IN THE CITY OF
DRAMA.
YOU HAD TO MUSCLE UP AND HUSTLE
TONIGHT.
AS LeBRON JAMES LEADS THE WAY,
AS THE LAKERS WIN, 106-101.
COMING UP